[Música]
ah
el presidente de donald trump sigue
despertando polémica debido a los
eventos que está realizando como parte
de su gira para la reelección y es que
el mandatario realizó un evento con
miles de personas en wisconsin no tenían
máscaras no estaban guardando
distanciamiento social y se espera que
continúe haciendo lo mismo la próxima
visita será ohio y también hay varios
eventos multitudinarios planeados las
últimas encuestas están mostrando a
bailén con una diferencia a su favor de
siete puntos por encima de donald trump
esto lo ha dicho a reuters e ipsos en
esta encuesta semanal y otro de los
temas que ha generado polémica hacia el
presidente donde al yom es la decisión
de no permitir la descarga del aptitud
esta red social en donde para los
demócratas simplemente el presidente no
le gustan las críticas o vídeos que se
hacen en su contra pero para el
presidente es un tema de seguridad
nacional
[Música]
queda un poco más de siete semanas para
que se celebren las elecciones
presidenciales y en estos momentos el
candidato demócrata joe biden lidera
todas las encuestas nacionales además
también gana en los swing states esos
estados bisagra en los que la mayoría de
sus votantes están indecisos pero serán
decisivos para llegar a la casa blanca o
quedarse en ella los estadounidenses
siguen dando su voto a tram cuando se
habla de economía pero en su respuesta
al coronavirus prefieren a joe biden
precisamente el candidato demócrata ha
estado meses dirigiéndose a sus votantes
de manera virtual pero ya ha empezado a
celebrar eventos en vivo y entrevistas
como la que tuvo lugar esta semana en
una cadena famosa de este país en la que
vimos al candidato demócrata seguro de
sí mismo y defender dos ideas
fundamentales que ya hemos escuchado
varias veces una que eeuu está inseguro
bajo el mandato de donald trump y dos
que dubai de en el candidato demócrata
él es el único que puede mantener unido
a un país que en estos momentos se
encuentra tremendamente polarizado
[Música]
la campaña política aquí en el estado de
california sigue siendo un tanto fría y
por ahora solo se ve actividad con la
candidata a vicepresidenta kamala harris
que es senadora de este estado y quien
sigue haciendo reuniones en el partido
demócrata para motivar un poco más a los
partidarios en este estado que ya se
saben han ganado durante los últimos 25
años en las elecciones por su parte los
republicanos siguen muy preocupados
porque no están de acuerdo con la
votación vía correo físico y además con
los violentos y fuertes incendios que
hay en este estado muchos lugares
rurales no tendrán la oportunidad ni
siquiera de hacerlo por
correo de esta manera se complica el
tema de cómo va a ser la votación y
también hay preocupación por el nuevo
sistema de votación que es electrónico y
en las pasadas elecciones primarias tuvo
serios problemas
[Música]